يرون ان على العالم تحرك بانقاذ الراشد
انصار المجلس العسكري بوقف العقوبات ضد
بلادهم
الشعب
النيجري هو الضحيه
[موسيقى]
توتر سياسي ودبلوماسي وعسكري بين مجموعه
الاكواس والنيجر يتزامن وانتهاء المهله
المملوحه للمجلس العسكري باعاده الرئيس
محمد بازوم الى منصبه فما ابرز المسارات
المتوقعه بعد انقضاء المهله
هناك تصميم صارم من قبل رؤساء دولنا
وحكوماتنا على وضع حد للانقلابات وجعل
النيجر مثالا على ذلك
المسار الاول تمديد المهله هو احد
الخيارات المتاحه لدول غرب افريقيا
المعروفه بمجموعه الاكواس وذلك على الرغم
من عدم تحقيق جهود وساطتها اي تقدم يذكر
يرى البعض في هذا المسار التنازلا ومجازفه
كبيره لكنه في الوقت نفسه يحفظ ماء وجه
قاده دول المجموعه الذين يمكنهم تسويغ
الامر بانه رغبه منهم في منح المجلس
العسكري مزيدا من الوقت للعوده الى
الديمقراطيه
المسار الثاني انتقال السلطه وفق هذا
المسار يتفق المجلس العسكري والاكواس على
جدول زمني من اجل العوده الى الحكم
الديمقراطي في النيجر يتضمن اطلاق الرئيس
بازوم ومعتقلين سياسيين اخرين المسار
يتوقعه البعض لاسباب عده منها ان مجموعه
الاكواس سبق ان وافقت على عمليات انتقال
ديمقراطي في كل من مال وبوركينا فاسو
جارتين نيجر في منطقه الساحل واللتين
استولى فيهما الجيش على السلطه في السنوات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
المسار الثالث
التدخل العسكري وهو الخيار الاخير بحسب
وصف المسؤولين النيجيريين وسبق ان تحدث
عنه صراحه الرئيس النيجيري بولاتينوبو
لجات الى استخدام القوه العسكريه من قبل
على غرار التدخل في غامبي عام 2017 بعد ان
رفض الرئيس يحيى جاما التنحي عقب خسارته
في الانتخابات لكن بحسب خبراء فان هذا
الخيار يصعب تنفيذه وقد يؤدي الى انهيار
مجموعه الاكواس نفسها وذلك لاسباب
اولها مساحه النيجر التي تعد اكبر دوله في
غرب افريقيا وهو ما قد يجعل ارسال قوات
عسكريه اليها امرا صعبا على النقيض من
غابيا الصغيره التي تحيط بها السنغال
والمحيط الاطلسي الثاني ان نيجيريا التي
تراس المجموعه تواجه الكثير من التحديات
الامنيه في الداخل الثالث معارضه بعض
الدول الاوروبيه والافريقيه ولا سيما
بوركينا فاسو ومالي والجزائر لاي تدخل
عسكري
للجزائر احنا رافضين رفض تم وقطعي بالنسبه
للتدخل العسكري
[موسيقى]